du willst nicht verarschen oder ich sag
dir nahe weil ein freund vedat bringe
ich dich um du die schlägt die gläser
das ist nicht seine schuld
oder doch meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren es ist wieder zeit die
gehirnzellen zu verlieren es ist zeit
die existenz des lebens an sich auf
dieser erde zu hinterfragen es ist zeit
für eine neue folge von hilf mir ich hab
meine bisherigen hilfen videos
nachgedacht und dann habe ich mir
gedacht sebastian warum hörst du nicht
mal auf dich darüber lustig zu machen wo
liegt der mehrwert für den zuschauer
darin wenn du dich über hilfen erfolgen
lustig machst mach doch mal hilft mir
video wo leute wirklich was für ihr
leben mitnehmen können und
logischerweise ist dann die wahl auf die
äußerst lehrreiche und realitätsnahe
hilfe folge totaler blackout ist antonia
keine jungfrau mehr gefallen wir kennen
alle die statistiken leute um die 310
millionen menschen wachen jedes jahr in
deutschland auch und fragen sich ob sie
noch immer an der stelle noch nicht ganz
sicher wie so etwas passieren kann aber
für alle da draußen die sich fragen bin
ich eigentlich noch jungfrau und die
antwort nicht sicher wissen ist diese
folge
aber kommen wir erst noch zum top
kommentar unter dem letzten hilfen video
den hatte ich noch nicht vorgestellt er
kommt von nissan uhr tee und lautet und
die moral von der geschicht vögel die
tochter deines freundes nicht es könnte
deine sein muss los wurde aber jetzt
sollte ganz ehrlich scheiß auf die
veranstalter auf die witze widmen wir
unsere aufmerksamkeit dieser lehrreichen
ratgeber folge
[Musik]
erste frage wer zur hölle ist diese
etwas korpulentere mensch lebt ich weiß
nicht warum aber der irgendwie kriegt
der mich aus somit ist wie eine zweite
frage warum schlafen die beiden unter
einer bettdecke die das muster von einem
putzlappen hat dritte frage soll das
eine türklingel sein wissen um das klang
das klagen wir diese glöckchen die diese
schoko osterhasen so um den hals tragen
ist doch keine partie klingelte nicht so
übel sein film und der typ dahinter so
ein koma und da haben wir unsere liebe
protagonistin antonia die sich scheinbar
nicht mehr als sicher ist ob sie noch
eine junge frau ist aber ganz ehrlich
ich dabei antonia könnte eine der
chancen nicht mehr charaktere sein wenn
anders als alle anderen fragt sie sich
bereits in den ersten zehn sekunden was
macht hier und die damit verbundene
frage ist natürlich nicht was mache ich
im bett von diesen menschen der gerade
um gegen des monats träumt sondern was
mache ich hier beihilfen zu machen ich
klinge schon seit 5 ein gesicht wenn du
ein schlaganfall kriegst weil so die
zahl fünf aussprechen willst was soll
jetzt in dieser szene her sagen leute in
jeder anderen serie könnte das einfach
eine x-beliebige person seien beihilfen
mir glaube ich ist das was ist ihr
freund
die hat sich ja etwas eingeholt wie hat
sich die ich weiß nicht mehr ob ich eine
jungfrau bin krankheit eingeholt die
sehr verbreitet ist in deutschland okay
an alle in den kommentaren sie jetzt
denken ihr opfer alter diese krankheit
ist kein spaß
wo echt krass okay ich hab gar den
vorrang bekommen dass bis zu 450
millionen in deutschland nicht wissen ob
sie noch jungfrau sind
ich dachte wir wurden
los sein ich hab nur überraschen was
stimmt hier warten wir noch verabredet
aber ich muss wieder heißt das dann
bekommst du deinen überraschung jetzt ja
als wir jetzt mehr antrag macht lasst
uns das ist eine situation wie kennt
alle leute wir wachen morgens auch unter
einem putzlappen gewissen einmal nicht
mehr ob wir noch jungfrau sind dann
klingelt die osterhasen glocke acar tür
klingelt und dann geht man natürlich
besonders an die tür und es ist
selbstverständlich der eigene freund der
einen nebenmann heiratsantrag macht
würde ich genauso machen so wenn meine
freundin zu sagen würde ja ich kann
heute doch nicht so und ich wollte hat
mit den wirklich schönen ort fahren ich
hatte eine kapelle bestellt ich hatte
ihre eltern da hingeschickt meine eltern
einfach um den perfekten moment für
unseren heiratsantrag zu machen
und wenn sie dann nicht mit kann dann
macht ihr den heiratsantrag im türrahmen
willst du mich heiraten heute an der
stelle ganz kurzen gruß an meine
zukünftige frau wenn ich den
heiratsantrag mache dann werde ich mir
schon unwahrscheinlich vielmehr dabei
geben dass das alles auch so schön ist
und so und ich wollte dich nur eine
sache bitten rändern vielleicht nicht
aufs clown kostet die seele aus dem leib
willst du mich heiraten
ich weiß echt nicht warum ich nach dem
luca wach geworden bin
die letzte nacht des wie weggeblasen
weggeblasen mich wirklich mit lucanet
schlafen ja ich liebe doch ali ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob ich den heiratsantrag an
dem tag ohne schlechtes gewissen zu
haben wohl diese stellungnahmen von mir
gehören der zeitablauf der folge ist ja
heiratsantrag direkt aufs klo kosten
dann so ok alle weist ganz kurz ich weiß
du bist so wird so ich habe auch keine
kosten natürlich mit den heiratsantrag
gemacht das okay aber ich muss ganz kurz
für die hilf mir folge ein statement
abgeben danach kommt hier die update das
mal vor einer echten leben so dirr desto
eher haben und was willst du mich
heiraten
was ich sagen wollte
ich bin ein bisschen verwirrt habe mich
mit mir schlafen nicht alle kurzsichtig
geplant ein interview oder eventuell der
lachs verstecken oder nicht dass die
frage reden die beiden typen wurde das
sind rein gekommen hat antonia gesehen
nur mit einer decke bekleidet hat ja
heiratsantrag gemacht die altert wie
kommt es ganz normal geht weiter aber
dann sieht er diesen luca im bett seiner
freundin schlafen ja heute erst mal
kaffee trinken ja okay ich bekomme dort
aus der regie den hinweis mal einen
blick in die beschreibung zu werfen da
steht dass luca 20 der mitbewohner von
antonia 18 ist hat das volle trotzdem
gesehen dass luca mit seiner freundin
einem bett geschlafen aber dass ihr
mitbewohner hat man kann der mittel wohl
eher nicht davon abhalten miteinander
schlafen wohnen zusammen
[Musik]
das ist auch ein ganz klassisches
symptom von wenn ich noch jungfrau ist
nicht nur weiß man nicht mehr auf meinen
letzten acht hat oder nicht sondern man
fühlt sich zusätzlich auch noch kraftlos
und motiviert weil es
das ist einfach nur bedingt ein bisschen
bedenkzeit oder bedenkt liebesdrama
reger aber luca im hintergrund boxer
überhaupt nicht trinkt seinen kaffee der
es gibt einfach seinen kaffee und denkt
darüber nach aber die kommen es mit
ketchup damit meine ich wirklich ganz
ehrlich leute den stressigen phasen des
lebens muss man einfach die coolness
bewahren und der direkt neben einem eine
langjährige beziehung in die brüche geht
ein paar tropfen und den cafés ippen
nicht vergessen wer denkt sich so und
ich meine mitbewohnerin genagelt
wahrscheinlich ist deswegen so ruhig
weil dass ich wieder übelste box für
sein café und treibt sie innerlich davon
wie so eine 100 meter hohe stufen ihm
gebaut wird
sie dauerte luca wirklich zugeschlagen
anschaffen miteinander geschlafen
ich glaube mir leute luca fühlt sich
glauben ja der freiheit sein leben
gerade weil wir waren ja haben wir dazu
könnte also ja gut meint heute als dass
ich junge frau bin um mich zu heiraten
da war was soll's dinge passieren denn
dass irgendjemand erfährt bringe ich
dich um hat mich verstanden du held
seine fresse du weißt dass ich mit an
bord
dass sich interessenten können wir das
gesamte ganz ehrlich wenn ich luca wehre
ich mich noch zeiten ich würde als aller
erstes mal eine fernsehkampagne in
auftrag geben prosiebensat 1 rtl zdf hd
budget 4 millionen titel
ich habe mir nie geschlafen und danach
vielleicht noch ein paar 10.000 plakate
in der stadt war dann würde ich ein ja
nicht weiter darüber reden
du hast mich ins bett legte klose das
ist nicht seine schuld
okay ganz kurz sollte man theorie von
mir meine theorie ist dass luca
möglicherweise antonia irgendwelche
drogen statt zu sagen was in meiner
bisherigen hilfe erfahrung halte ich das
für ein nicht ganz unwahrscheinlich sei
ich weiß aber ganz ehrlich so schlimm
dass es auch nicht man macht einfach so
den übergang von ich bin jung wozu ich
weiß nicht ob jung von matt
sie sagte nicht dass sie keine jungfrau
ist nicht mehr mein mitbewohner lokalen
ja genau ich konnte das passieren
man muss sich wirklich meinem leben und
manchmal ist eben auch der zeitpunkt
gekommen wo man sich seinen mitbewohner
können muss wenn luca hat es vielleicht
auch noch mit der love at bischofsheim
ii stand vor der tür und hat mir ein
heiratsantrag gemacht und was habe ich
natürlich gesagt dass ich bedenkzeit
brauchen bedenkzeit ist das wort
auszumachen du nichts gesagt du wirst
uns klo gerannt gekommen weil ich davor
mit nur einem bett war verschießen die
ganze geschichte jetzt
ich komme gar nicht mehr klar wissen
nicht wirklich was bei ihnen ich habe
ihn angerufen er hat mich die ganze zeit
unterdrückt und jetzt ist er bestimmt so
auf mich und er will mich nicht mehr
heiraten und das beste ist ich kann
ihnen nicht mehr heiraten verstehst und
verstehe ich hatte ehrlich gesagt nicht
da muss ich ja die auch noch mal
explizit kritisieren nur weil deine
freundin ins klo gekotzt hat macht beim
heiratsantrag ist es keinen grund sie zu
ignorieren brauchen verstehst du dass
ihr beide in unserer heraus nach einer
jungen frauen sind ja ich glaube das
wird nix sie denken sie auch so ey was
soll die scheiße ich vermerke zur arbeit
mit meinen job machen
ich weiß aber meine mitarbeiter nicht
mehr ob sie jugend frau ist oder nicht
hat schon mal mit ihrem mitarbeiter
geschlafen und kann auf einmal ihr
ehemann ich mache gar keinen bock auf
die kacke sich einfach erst mal am
besten geht es später zum frauenarzt
feststellen ob du noch jungfrau bischof
dann kam er als noch verstarb du
vielleicht schwanger bist oder nicht ich
stimme daran habe ich ja gar nicht
gedacht wie man kann von sechs fahrer
werden das wusste ich nicht was kann man
sonst denken wenn man ohne zu rücken
sex hat man kann genau das richtige
denken entweder irgendeine krankheit
oder schwanger sei ich weiß nicht was er
dabei gedacht hat oder was du gedacht da
von den einkauf von morgen oder wie das
war soweit mit dem ersten teil leute der
zweite teil kommt morgen oder übermorgen
ihr könnt bis dahin hier einfach
persönlich vorgestellt das video
abchecken und weiter gucken und
reingucken slubice